ابرز ما يدور على الساحه التركيه من
عناوين الصحف التركيه هذا الصباح المواليه
والمعارضه صحيفه صباح المواليه تقول
المواطن صوت للانجازات وليس للثرثره وهكذا
سيقرر في جوله الاعاده حريه المواليه تقول
تعرفنا على جوله الاعاده للمره الاولى في
تاريخ ديمقراطيهنا صحيفه تركيا المواليه
تقول هزيمه الطاوله السداسيه اي المعارضه
اكشن المواليه تقول الفائز هو الديمقراطيه
التركيه صحيفه جمهوريه المعارضه الان تقول
سنفوز اما السوسو المعارضه
كانت جدا اليوم وقالت يبدو ان الشعب شبعان
وشبعان تعني بالتركي
بالكاف وهناك سياره ممتازه تركيا محليا
جديده اسم اسمها توغ بالغين فهناك لعب على
الكلام في هذا المعنى في اشاره الى الغلاء
المعيشي